Bernie Sanders' young supporters
have been incredibly passionate
during his campaign,
and now that it's all over
they're understandably
emotional.
♪
(laughter)
Comedians, in the spirit
of party unity, what's something
you might say to cheer up
these forlorn delegates? Sarah.
Don't worry, you can reuse that
hat at the Renaissance Faire.
-(laughter)
-Yes. Points.
-Yeah, you could.
-(applause)
Uh... I want to point out
there's nothing wrong
with going
to the Renaissance Faire.
-Chris.
-Uh...
Dude, it's okay.
You're still white.
-All right, points. Points.
-(laughter, applause)
Tony.
Don't worry, guys, your parents
will give you more money
to spend on other things.
All right, points. Points.